Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Cromwell, our chief of men, who through a cloud, not of war only, but detractions rude, guided by faith and matchless fortitude, to peace and truth thy glorious way has ploughed, and on the neck of crowned fortune proud, hast reared God's trophies. That was John Milton writing a sonnet in honour of Oliver Cromwell in 1652, three years after the execution of Charles I, and shortly before, to Milton's horror,
感谢收听《历史的剩余》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。克伦威尔，我们的杰出领袖，你穿过重重阴云——不仅有战争的阴云，还有恶毒的诽谤，在信仰和无与伦比的坚韧指引下，开辟了通往和平与真理的光荣道路，并将上帝的战利品高高竖立在骄傲的加冕权贵的颈项之上。这是约翰·米尔顿（John Milton）于1652年为奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell）创作的一首十四行诗，当时正值查理一世被处决三年后，而在不久之后，令米尔顿感到惊恐的是，
Cromwell would become Lord Protector. With me is noted roundhead Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic.brook. Dominic. Thanks for that, Tom. That's a lovely introduction. Would you agree with Milton in lording Cromwell in that way? Are you a fan?
克伦威尔将成为护国公。与我同在的是著名的圆颅党人多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。多米尼克。谢谢你，汤姆。这是一段精彩的开场白。你会像米尔顿那样赞美克伦威尔吗？你是他的粉丝吗？
I am a fan, actually. I think you can probably divide people, can't you, into... There was that old line, you know, what side would you have fought on at Marston Moor? And I think you can divide people into Cromwellians and non-Cromwellians. I'm definitely a Cromwellian. In my view, Tom, and this is a big statement, Cromwell is my favourite British political leader. Even better than Stanley Baldwin, in my mind, and Jim Callaghan.
其实我是他的粉丝。我觉得人们大概可以分成两派，不是吗？过去有这样一句老话：如果在马斯顿莫尔战役（Marston Moor），你会加入哪一方？我想人们可以分为克伦威尔派和非克伦威尔派。我绝对是个克伦威尔派。依我之见，汤姆——这是一个很大的断言——克伦威尔是我最喜欢的英国政治领袖。在我心中，他甚至比斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）和吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callaghan）还要好。
I think Cromwell is right up there, right at the top. I love Cromwell. I think he's so interesting. So interesting. Favourite in the sense that he's the most interesting British as in as in you admire his achievement I think actually you know what both I I uh and I admire him for the fact he had he was in a position that no other Englishman has ever been in other than Richard Cromwell his son being law protector having supreme power and I think by and large um you know power reveals character and I think it revealed
我认为克伦威尔绝对名列前茅，位于最顶端。我喜欢克伦威尔。我觉得他太有趣了。太有趣了。说他是最喜欢的，是指他最有意思的英国人，还是说你钦佩他的成就？其实我觉得，两者皆有。我之所以钦佩他，是因为他处于一个从未有其他英国人（除了他的儿子理查德·克伦威尔担任过护国公、拥有最高权力之外）达到过的地位，而且总的来说，你知道，权力能展现性格，我认为它把
him in a pretty good light actually I think you know it didn't corrupt particularly he didn't behave especially badly now I know Irish listeners are already you know throwing their phones across the the room in fury but by and large I'm a big big Cromwell fan okay well as you suggested there are lots of people who would disagree with that verdict on Cromwell I mean he he was the leader of one side in a civil war so obviously royalists by and large tend not to be keen on him. And you mentioned Ireland, and in Ireland, his name is basically Mudd. So we need someone to guide us, I think, through the complexities and the ambivalences and the ambiguities, not just of Cromwell's life, but of the period that we're particularly focusing on in this episode,
他展现得相当好。我觉得权力并没有特别腐蚀他，他的行为也没有特别恶劣。我知道爱尔兰听众现在可能已经气得把手机扔向房间各处了，但总的来说，我是克伦威尔的超级大粉丝。好吧，正如你所暗示的，有很多人不同意对克伦威尔的这种评价。我的意思是，他是内战中一方的领袖，所以保皇党人显然大都不太喜欢他。而且你提到了爱尔兰，在爱尔兰，他的名字简直臭名昭著。所以我想我们需要有人来引导我们，厘清其中的复杂性、矛盾性和模糊性——不仅是克伦威尔一生的，还有我们在本期节目中特别关注的那个时期的复杂性，
which is, I guess you'd call it the British Republic, the period from Charles I's execution up to the restoration of his son, Charles II. And there is no better person to provide us with that guidance than Paul Leigh, who is editor of History Today, but also, more saliently for our purposes, author of a fabulous book, Providence Lost, The Rise and Fall of Cromwell's Protectorate, absolutely garlanded with praise. So Paul, thanks so much for coming on and joining us. And can you help us out, Cromwell, hero or zero? Well, neither, of course. I agree with Dominic to a certain extent that he's the most fascinating character. But he's the most fascinating character.
我想你可以称之为英国共和国，也就是从查理一世被处决到其子查理二世复辟这段时期。没有人比保罗·莱（Paul Ley）更能为我们提供这种指导了，他是《今日历史》（History Today）杂志的编辑，但对我们而言更重要的是，他是那本广受赞誉的畅销书《天意丧失：克伦威尔护国政权的兴衰》（Providence Lost, The Rise and Fall of Cromwell's Protectorate）的作者。所以，保罗，非常感谢你来到这里加入我们。你能帮我们评判一下，克伦威尔究竟是英雄还是狗熊？嗯，当然两者都不是。在某种程度上，我同意多米尼克的看法，即他是最迷人的人物。但他也是个极其迷人的人物，
But he's also, and I think this is what makes him even more fascinating for me, is that he's incredibly elusive. And I think this is why the man lends himself to mythology. There's always an awful lot to fill in with Cromwell. I mean, this is a man who's almost nothing for the first two thirds of his life. He barely exists in the records. And then suddenly, at the age of 43, he becomes, or he sets out on a career as one of the great cavalry commanders in British history, and we can discuss where he ranks there. But then he becomes this, as Dominic says, this almost unique figure. And I think he is unique because Richard is not remotely comparable, really, apart from the position he holds for a brief while.
而且——我想这也是他对我而言更具吸引力的原因——他极其难以捉摸。我想这也是为什么这个人总是充满神话色彩。关于克伦威尔，总有大量的空白需要去填补。我的意思是，这个人生命的前三分之二几乎默默无闻，他在记录中几乎不存在。然后突然之间，在43岁时，他成为或开始了他作为英国历史上最伟大的骑兵指挥官之一的职业生涯，我们可以讨论他在其中的排位。但随后，正如多米尼克所说，他成为了这个几乎独一无二的人物。我认为他是独一无二的，因为理查德除了在短时间内担任过那个职位之外，其实根本无法与之相比。
He is this unique head of state who tries to create something that I think is born of a kind of moral and theological endeavour. And in some sense, the legacy is a continuous one. The monarchy never returns, even after the Restoration, in the sense that it was before that. There's never a kind of Charles's personal rule or anything like that. Parliament becomes in the ascendant over that time. There are still things to be worked out. Essentially, he does define us and i think the battle that he waged the ideas that he waged are still resonant now and i think in particular um of gs elliott's poem a little hitting in the
他成为了这个独特的国家元首，试图创造出我认为某种源于道德和神学努力的事物。从某种意义上说，这种遗产是连续的。即使在复辟之后，君主制也再也没有回到以前那种状态。再也没有查理一世时期的个人统治之类的事情了。从那时起，议会开始占据主导地位。当然还有很多事情需要解决。从根本上说，他定义了我们，而且我认为他所进行的斗争、他所推崇的理念至今仍产生着共鸣。我想到了T·S·艾略特（T. S. Eliot）在《四首四重奏》（Four Quartets）中的诗句，当他谈到国家内部和我们内心深处竞相争斗的火与玫瑰时，通常就像吉尔伯特与沙利文（Gilbert and Sullivan）的那句台词：每个活着的男孩和女孩都有点自由主义倾向，或者有点保守主义倾向。在某种程度上，我们在克伦威尔身上看到了这些斗争，在克伦威尔对铸造国家如此重要的过程中也看到了这些斗争。但是，保罗，难道最有趣的地方不正在于他并非只有一点点自由主义或保守主义倾向，而是任何一方都可以将他拉拢到自己这边？这不正是他最迷人的地方吗？他以某种方式包容了所有英国政治，你不这么认为吗？是的，我想他确实如此，因为我认为左翼有很多人视他为英雄，仅仅因为他们将他视为一个共和主义者。当然，右翼也有很多人认为他
four quartets when he talks about the fire and the rose that compete within the nation and compete within ourselves often i think like the gilbert the Gilbert and Sullivan line that every boy and girl alive is a little bit liberal or a little bit conservative. And those are the battles that we see in Cromwell to a certain extent, but in the nation that Cromwell was so important in forging. But Paul, isn't the interesting thing that he's not a little liberal or a little conservative, that either side can claim him and that's what's so fascinating about him, that he contains all, in a way, he contains all English politics, don't you think? Yes, I think he does, because I think there's a lot of people on the left who regard him as heroic because they see him as a Republican for that alone. And there are of course of people on the right who seem as
同样重要，因为他是一个英国民族主义者。他有着深刻的英国例外论思想，同时他也是宗教自由的捍卫者。当然，天主教徒肯定会反驳这一点，但就他致力于建立一个在17世纪中期标准来看相当宽容的宗教妥协方案而言，他是一个相当了不起的人物。而且他在
important because he's an English nationalist he has this profound idea of English exceptionalism he is a defender of religious liberty too I think I mean Catholics obviously would counter that but in terms of his commitment to a really quite capacious religious settlement, certainly by the standards of the mid 17th century, he's a pretty remarkable figure. And he also has this central role
英国军队缔造者的角色中也起到了核心作用，我想这一点有时可能被遗忘了。还有舰队，不是吗？是的，这也很重要。他曾拥有一艘名为“马斯顿莫尔”号的战舰，
as one of the creators of the British Army, too, that I think is probably sometimes forgotten. And the fleet, didn't he? Yes, well, that's important. He had a battleship called the Marston Moor,
我一直觉得这很酷，这是我从你的书里了解到的。有那么多以莫尔命名的战舰吗？没有。其实，说起马斯顿莫尔，我突然觉得，对于那些对各种内战战役等等并不是完全了解的听众来说，也许在我们深入探讨克伦威尔本人、护国政权以及其他事情之前，我们应该先铺垫一下关键内容。多米尼克，你很擅长这个。用30秒简单总结一下内战。来吧。谢谢你，汤姆。谢谢你，汤姆。好吧，我上周确实成功总结了《权力的游戏》，而且没有引发推特上的狂热。所以，
which I always thought was very cool, which I learned from your book. There's so many battleships named after Moors, are there? No. And actually, you know, talking about Marston Moor, it suddenly strikes me that perhaps for people who aren't entirely on top of all their various Civil War battles and so on, perhaps we should just set key things up before we get on to Cromwell himself and the Protectorate and everything. Dominic, you're very good at that. Just quickly give a very quick breakdown of sum up the Civil War in 30 seconds. Go on. Thank you, Tom. Thank you, Tom. Well, I did manage to sum up Game of Thrones last week without Twitter going wild. So, well,
英国内战是一个棘手的话题。它真的是英国内战吗？好吧，那是另一个完全不同的问题了。好吧，保罗，你得原谅我这一点。基本上，你身处17世纪的英国或17世纪的布列塔尼（不列颠）。查理一世一直在没有议会的情况下独断专行。他有点自认为是个绝对君主。但在1630年代末，一切似乎同时出了问题。
the English Civil War is a tough one. And is it the English Civil War? Well, that's a whole different question. Okay, well, Paul, you have to forgive me for this. So basically, you're in 17th century England or 17th century Britain. Charles I has been ruling on his own without parliament. He slightly sort of seems to fancy himself as an absolute monarch. But at the end of the 1630s, everything kind of goes wrong at once.
爱尔兰爆发了一场大暴动，那里一直弥漫着一种暗流涌动的怨气，夹杂着天主教的不满以及英国新教的影响等等。与此同时，由于查理试图强行推行一本祈祷书，与苏格兰人爆发了叛乱或战争。因此，这三个王国中有两个可以说是处于叛乱状态。
So there's a big rebellion in Ireland where there's been sort of discontent simmering and there's sort of Catholic resentment, sort of English Protestantism and stuff. At the same time, there is a rebellion or a war breaks out with the Scots over a prayer book that Charles is trying to impose. So two of these three kingdoms are, as it were, in revolt.
对苏格兰人的战争进展得非常糟糕。查理需要更多的钱。而他获得资金的唯一途径就是重新召集议会。但议会不喜欢他，他们水火不容。他竖起大旗说，你们知道的，集合起来支持我对抗议会，于是国王与议会之间爆发了内战——也就是熟悉这些术语的人所说的保皇党（骑士党）与圆颅党之间的内战。所以你经历了这样一场多方交织的内战。长话短说，第一次内战对查理来说进展得极其糟糕，
The war goes very bad against the Scots. Charles needs more money. And the only way he can get more money is by recalling Parliament. But Parliament doesn't like him. they're at loggerheads he raises his standard and says you know rally to me against parliament and civil war breaks out between king and parliament so between cavaliers and roundheads for people who are familiar with those terms so you've got this sort of multi-faceted civil war it's a kind of very long story short the first civil war goes very badly for charles he But at that point, the parliamentarians don't want to kill him and they don't want to sort of kick him out or anything. They believe in the monarchy. They just want a better deal with
但就在那时，议会派并不想杀他，也不想把他赶下台之类。他们信仰君主制。他们只是想和查理达成更好的协议。所以他们一直在和查理谈判。他们把他软禁起来，试图与他达成协议，而且他们以为自己能达成协议。但查理却背着他们行事。他与苏格兰人达成了秘密协议——苏格兰人是他的三个王国之一，但可以说是他以前的敌人。苏格兰人随后大举进犯议会派，现在爆发了第二次内战。所以这个极其复杂的故事出现了《权力的游戏》式的转折。
Charles. So they're talking to Charles. They've got him kind of locked up and they're trying to get a deal with him and they think they're going to get a deal. But Charles goes behind their back. He does a secret deal with the Scots, so one of his three kingdoms, but sort of his old enemy, as it were. The Scots pile in against the parliamentarians, and there's now a second civil war. So this incredibly complicated story has taken this Game of Thrones star twist.
好吧，发生了第二次内战，但由于其新模范军（New Model Army）的功劳，议会再次赢得了胜利，而这支军队的领袖正是奥利弗·克伦威尔。现在他们赢得了两场内战。他们决定无法与查理达成任何协议，因为事实证明他完全不可信。他正是他们所称的“血腥之人”、叛国者、把人民出卖给反基督者的代理人。所以他必须走人。于是他们决定砍掉他的头。他们进行了一场作秀审判。他的头落地了。这就引发了一个问题：接下来我们到底该怎么办？
Well, the second civil war, but the parliament wins that as well, thanks to its new model army, of which the sort of leading light is Oliver Cromwell. So now they've won two civil wars. They've decided that they can't do any sort of deal with Charles because he's proved himself utterly untrustworthy. He is, as they call him, the man of blood, the traitor to his country, sort of agent
而正是在这个节点上，这位伟大的新模范军骑兵将军、前议会派“煽动者”奥利弗·克伦威尔全面登上了历史舞台。这也是我们可以把话题交回给保罗的时候吗，多米尼克？我觉得保罗接下来应该负责剩下的所有发言了。好吧，那比预期要稍微长了一点，但非常非常精彩。好的，保罗，请给我们简单勾勒一下，当克伦威尔以及克伦威尔的谈判代表和与他同道的人与查理的谈判失败后，发生了什么？查理上了断头台，他的头被砍掉了。接下来发生了什么？这只是非常小的一群人做出一个非常非常大胆的决定，却不知道接下来该做什么。因此，当务之急是立即稳定国家。这其实并没有什么特别的不同。这并没有特别困难。经历过内战的英格兰，就像所有经历过内战的国家一样，渴望和平，渴望某种形式的稳定。记住，这是霍布斯的时代。甚至连霍布斯——这位年轻流亡查理二世的前数学家庭教师——也是一个向政权寻求和平的人。因此，有很多人希望达成妥协。但同时也存在着巨大的阻力。苏格兰有一些阻力，尽管总体而言，英国议会对其同胞加尔文主义者的态度相当温和。但随后便是爱尔兰问题，这是随着新宣布的英联邦的诞生而采取的第一个重大行动——对爱尔兰的征服。
of the Antichrist who has betrayed his people. So he's got to go. So they decide to cut his head off. They have a show trial. Off goes his head. And then that raises the question, well, what on earth are we going to do next and that's the point at which this great new model army cavalry general and former parliamentarian sort of um firebrand oliver cromwell fully enters the stage and is this also the point where we can go back to paul dominic
这就是我们进入某种英国共和国、即英联邦的阶段。上议院被废除了。议会占据上风。君主制不复存在。这是我们最接近那种状态的时期。但在其中，克伦威尔只是“同辈中的第一人”（primus inter paris），一个仅仅因为过去在纳斯比等战役以及苏格兰战役中的功绩而在军事和政治上扮演重要角色的人。因此他拥有这样的声誉，但在审判和处决之外的角色上，他尚未成为一个真正的政治人物。所以此时此刻仍有许多事情需要决定。各种可能性都存在。保罗，我可以插话把时间稍微拉回一点吗？所以当时的克伦威尔，他在战前曾是一名议员。他在战争期间是一位出色的骑兵指挥官。
i think paul should now do all the rest of the talking yeah okay that was that was slightly longer than expected but very very, very good. OK, so Paul, just give us the brief sketch of what happens when Cromwell and the negotiators of Cromwell and others like him with Charles fails. Charles goes to the block, his head's chopped off. What then happens? Just a very brief group of people making a very, very bold decision, but not knowing what to do next. And so there's an urgency immediately to settle the country. That's not particularly different. That's not particularly difficult. England, after civil war, like all countries after civil war, seeks peace and wants some kind of stability. Remember, this is the age of Hobbes. And even Hobbes, the former mathematics
但他是怎样的一个人呢？我的意思是，如果你遇到他，他会是怎样的一个人？显然他曾经历过“重生”，不是吗？他是一个某种意义上的“重生的基督徒”，但他同时也很世俗、好辩，而且常常相当暴躁。我的意思是，如果你走进一个房间，他就在那里，他作为一个人是什么样的？嗯，我觉得他并不是一个天生的——或者至少不是我们所认为的那种天生的17世纪清教徒。这是一个会喝酒的人，一个会抽烟的人，一个喜欢音乐的人。他虽然不是个知识分子，但说到这里，斯派克·塞尔（Spike Searle）有一个非常棒的问题：“克伦威尔早期的板球生涯在哪些方面影响了他后来的宗教信仰？”我觉得这非常重要。
tutor to the young, exiled Charles II, for example, is one who finds his peace with the regime. So there's a lot of people who want to reach a settlement. But there's also a great deal of opposition. There's some in Scotland, although on the whole, the English Parliament is reasonably well disposed to their fellow Calvinists on the home. But then there is the issue of Ireland, which is the first great act, the conquest of Ireland, that takes place with this Commonwealth that's been announced. Here is the bit where we are in a kind of English Republic, a Commonwealth.
是的，他非常热衷于板球，据他年轻时的记录，他甚至还踢过足球。但当然，他后来因在安息日禁止打板球而臭名昭著，这某种程度上总结了那种张力，不是吗？保龄球手、击球手，到处都是……你知道的，我觉得他并不热衷于那些。他曾代表过小郡队吗？我本来想说他的出生地，我不确定。我不认为他会涉及那个。在他交代了自己的出生地之后，他曾代表过小郡队吗？我不确定。我不知道。我不知道。但我的意思是，他是一个“铁骑军”（Ironside），我猜。
The House of Lords has been abandoned. Parliament is in the Ascendant. The monarchy is gone. This is the closest we get to that. But within that, Cromwell is a primus inter paris, someone who merely has a substantial military and political role because of his deeds in the past, whether that's at events like Naseby and in the Scottish campaign. And so he has this reputation, but as yet, he's not a political figure beyond his role in the trial and execution. So there's still a lot to decide at this point. All kinds of possibilities are possible. And Paul, can I jump in and take us back a tiny bit? So Cromwell at that point, he'd been an MP before the war. He'd been a fantastic cavalry commander during the war.
所以很可能是个击球手。好吧，这清楚地解释了为什么他后来想去西印度群岛并在那里获得领地，我猜。也许吧，我不知道。也许板球就是在那时被引入的。第一次加勒比巡回赛。我想我们有些跑题了。无论如何，我想指出的是，
But what kind of a man, I mean, if you'd met him, what kind of a man was he? I mean, obviously he was born again, wasn't he? He's a sort of born again christian but he's also earthy and and disputatious and often quite angry and i mean i mean if you know if you walked into a room and there he is what's he what's he like as a man well i don't think he's a natural or at least what we think of as a natural 17th century puritan uh this is a man who drinks this is a man who smokes this is a man who enjoys music he seems he's no intellectual but on that note great question from spike searle who says in what way did cromwell's early cricketing career influences later religious beliefs i think that's very important to
他完全能够喜欢板球、音乐、绘画或诸如此类的东西。但与此同时，很明显，宗教就是他的全部。我们该如何看待这种悖论？如何圆这个方圆？我怀疑最终——这也是多米尼克所暗指的——那种“海绿色的 incorruptible（清廉正直）”的想法在很大程度上其实是存在的。上帝决定什么，事情就会怎么发生。
yeah he was very keen on cricket and he played football apparently according to when he was a young man but then of course he's notorious for for banning cricket on on the sabbath day and that kind of sums up the uh the tension doesn't it um bowler batsman all around you know i don't think he's into that did he represent the minor counties i was going to give his birthplace i'm not sure i don't think he goes into that. Did he represent the minor counties after he's given his birthplace? I'm not sure. I don't know. I don't know. But I mean, he's an Ironside, I guess.
我的意思是，他完全适应了预定论（predestination）的思想，即一切都已经注定。他只是在寻找自己是否站在正确的一边，是否在执行上帝的意志。在这个框架内，对于某种加尔文主义者来说，有相当大的空间。如果一个人注定得救，那他无论如何都会得救。我不认为他在追求快乐方面是个恶毒的清教徒。我的意思是，有许多关于他在女儿婚礼上喝醉酒、跳舞、开玩笑的精彩故事。还有那些著名的记载（无论是否属实）：当签署婚姻登记册时，他把墨水甩到别人脸上。你知道的，对于这些事情，你必须要持保留态度。
So probably a batsman. Well, it makes clear why he'd wish to go to the West Indies, I suppose, and gain possessions there. Maybe, I don't know. Maybe cricket was introduced at that point. The first Caribbean tour. I think we're getting distracted here. Anyway, the point I wanted to make was
同样，我们面临着神话色彩、克伦威尔的难以捉摸性，以及历史记录的开放性。但从各方记载来看，这个人并不符合与那个时代紧密相连的那种极其严苛的清教主义——比如赞美上帝·巴恩伯恩（Praise-God Barebone），甚至像米尔顿那样的人，我认为米尔顿在那种道德和行为意义上或许是一个更加可怕的清教徒。
that he's perfectly capable, say, of liking cricket or music or painting or whatever. But at the same time, he's clearly, religion is everything to him. How do we square that kind of paradox? Square that circle. I suspect that in the end, and I think this is something that Dominic alluded to, this idea of a sea green incorruptible, in many ways, I think is true to a certain extent. What God decides is what will happen anyway.
在我们回到严肃的政治之前，我必须在汤姆开口前问一句：他真的曾被一只猴子绑架过吗？千真万确。还有，作为一个小男孩时——我确信这是假的，但我确信我曾在《瓢虫书》（Lady Bird book）里读到过他和未来的查理一世打过架？
I mean, he is perfectly attuned to the idea of predestination, that it's all being worked out anyway. He's simply looking to see if he's on the right side and doing God's will. And within that, there's a fair amount of space for a certain kind of galvanist. If one is saved, one is saved anyway. And I don't think he's the kind of malicious Puritan in terms of pleasure. I mean, there are great stories about him being at his daughter's wedding where he's drunk and he's dancing and he's joking. There are, you know, the famous account, whether it's true or not, about him flicking ink at the time that the register was signed. You know, you have to take these things with a bit of a pinch of salt.
你确实读过。它们都出现在《瓢虫书》里。它们确实在《瓢虫书》里。我记得非常清楚。那本书里唯一认为爱尔兰人反对他的就是那一本，我猜。但我没有看到任何证据，而且我认为任何人都没有。
Again, we've got this mythology, the elusiveness of Cromwell, that openness of the record. But from all accounts, this is not a man who fits in with the very, very austere Puritanism that is associated with this time in figures such as, praise God, Bearburn, or even Milton, who I think was perhaps a more formidable Puritan in that kind of moral and behavioural sense.
但我很好奇这个故事是从哪里来的。好吧，我们的共同朋友泰德·瓦伦斯（Ted Vallance）曾写过这件事。他写过？我没看过。他把它追溯到，我想是19世纪初的一个出处。对，那就是你会想象得到的来源。是的，让我们回到正题吧。我们从政治话题上跑题了。抱歉，保罗，我用我的猴子话题把你带偏了。我把你从护国政权的政治话题中拉开了，所以让我们回到刚才的地方。这里有一个灰色地带，
Before we get back to the seriousness of the politics, I have to ask before Tom does, is it true that he was kidnapped by a monkey? Small. And is it also true that as a boy, I'm certain this is false, but I'm sure I read in the Lady Bird book that he had a fight with the future Charles I.
不是吗？查理被砍了头，接下来是：谁来管理英国？军队、议会还是别的什么？而在那个时候，克伦威尔基本上只是个军人，对吧？他并不是真正的政治人物，是这样吗？嗯，他是政治人物，在这个意义上：他在查理一世的审判和处决中扮演了非常突出的角色。我的意思是，我认为你可以看到某些议会派成员的态度发生了巨大转变，特别是克伦威尔，尤其是在第二次内战期间。因为我认为到那个时候，查理作为“血腥之人”的形象已经浮现。
You did. They were both in the Lady Bird book. They were in the Lady Bird book. I remember it very well. That's the book where only the Irish take against him, I believe. But I have seen no evidence, and I don't think anyone ever
甚至像克伦威尔这样对君主制抱有好感、绝非意识形态上的共和主义者的人，也对这个男人的两面三刀感到厌恶至极。他们认为摆脱困境的唯一途径就是对这个“血腥之人”进行审判并最终处决。但正如我所说，他们完全不知道接下来该做什么。仅出于安全原因，他们就必须处理好
has done. But I wonder where that story comes from. Well, our mutual friend Ted Vallance wrote about it. He did? I haven't seen that. He traced it back, I i think to an early 19th century source yeah no that's what you'd imagine yeah let's go back to we got on sidetracked from the politics sorry paul i took you off with my my monkey my monkey talk i took you off from the politics of the protectorate so let's go back to where we were there's this sort of gray area
苏格兰和爱尔兰的问题。但一旦爱尔兰被征服（克伦威尔在1650年参与其中），他们就必须寻求妥协。他们与议会达成了一种协议，即议会将基本上自行解散。但那并没有真正发生。我认为正是在那个时候，克伦威尔真正成为了主导人物。议会被赶下台了，它被缩减、被剥离。突然之间，需要某种新的妥协方案。对此有各种各样的尝试。但其中最初的一次议会尝试，我认为揭示了议会周围的人物在经历了以皮鞋匠、清教徒“赞美上帝·巴恩斯”为代表的事件后是多么的……
isn't there charles had a head cut off they kind of is who's going to run britain the the army the the parliament or whatever and at that point cromwell's just a soldier basically is he he's not really a political figure is that right well he's a political figure in the sense that he's played a very prominent role in the trial and execution of charles i mean i think you see a big shift between attitudes of certain parliamentarians particularly cromwellwell, rather during the Second Civil War. Because I think by that time, this idea of Charles as a man of blood emerges.
而这背后的蓝图——这也是托马斯·哈里森（Thomas Harrison）的脑洞大关，他曾与克伦威尔并肩作战，是一位将军，也是一个名为“第五帝国论派”（Fifth Monarchists）的群体的领袖。他们有着离奇的信仰，长话短说，他们将英格兰视为过去伟大帝国的继承者。他们认为，如果在英格兰实现了他们的政治和神学蓝图，基督就会作为这第五位君王降临，一切也将随之终结。所以，我的意思是，你确实能真切感受到当时存在的这种离奇信仰。即使在那个时代，它们也相当极端，
And even people like Cromwell, who are partial to the idea of monarchy, are not at all ideological Republicans, are sick to the back teeth of this man's duplicities. And they see the only way out of this is through trial and then ultimately execution of this man of blood. But as I said, they've absolutely no idea what to do next. They have to deal with, for security reasons alone,
而且当时绝对没有被英国公众所接受。这个机构被称为“提名议会”（Nominated Assembly），因为它本应由140名“内心有道”的人组成——即优秀、稳健的清教徒人物。
with Scotland and Ireland. But then once Ireland is conquered, to the extent that Cromwell's involved in it in 1650, they then have to reach for a settlement. And there is a kind of deal that's reached with the Parliament that it will make itself redundant, essentially. But that doesn't really happen. And I think that's the point when Cromwell really emerges as the dominant figure. And Parliament is just thrown out, it's reduced, it's denuded. And suddenly, some kind of new settlement is needed. And there are various experiments with this. But the first one of those parliamentary experiments is the one I think that reveals just how much the figures around Parliament, after a Puritan leather trader called Praise God Bare Bones.
他们本应由各个独立的教会提名，但实际上并非如此。其中大多数人是由国务会议（Council of State）决定的，国务会议当时与议会共同管理着国家。而且就其实践而言，它并没有你想象的那么疯狂（尽管它是以旧约中的犹太公会Sanhedrin为蓝本的），它确实通过了许多急需的法律改革。议会派周围总是有相当多的律师，
And what this is modelled on, and this is the brainchild of Thomas Harrison, who's fought alongside Cromwell, a general, who is the leader of a group called the Fifth Monarchists. Bizarre beliefs who, to cut a long story short, see England as being the inheritor of the great empires of the past. And that if they fulfill their political and theological plans in England, Christ will return as this fifth monarch and that will be the end of it all. So, I mean, you get a real sense of the kind of bizarre beliefs that you have here. There are pretty extreme, even by the time,
但它与军队发生了摩擦。这便是症结所在，因为这个十年中发生的最终一切事情，归根结底都取决于军队的力量。如果军队不想要它，它就无法真正发生。而克伦威尔之所以是个关键人物，是因为他是那个在当时拥有某种信任、或者说足以让双方都将自己的突出地位托付给他的人。然而，提名议会最终还是失败了，因为它没有给军队提供足够的资金。这是贯穿整个时期的共同主题。于是，另一位人物取代了托马斯·哈里森的位置（托马斯·哈里森退居边缘），而崭露头角的这个人，在当时被广泛视为——
and certainly are not ones adhered to by the English public at this point. And you have, it's called the Nominated Assembly because it's supposed to be filled with 140 people who have the root of the matter in them. Good, sound, Puritan
我们这里说的是1653-54年——他就是约翰·兰伯特（John Lambert）。他的军事生涯几乎和克伦威尔一样辉煌。在提名议会争吵不休的大部分时间里，他都在忙着起草世界上第一部成文宪法，即《政府约法》（Instrument of Government）。除许多其他事情外，这部宪法将国王、上议院和下议院的“三位一体”重新配置为一个新的三位一体（无论是否神圣）：护国公（Lord Protector）。这个职位将被提供给克伦威尔，因为人们知道他不太可能接受王冠；
figures. They're supposed to be nominated by the individual churches, independent churches, they're actually not. Most of them are decided by the council of state which along with common it's basically running things at this point um and it's by no means as mad in terms of the practices as you might think from the way it's modeled on the old testament sanhedrin it puts through quite a few reforms of the law that are much needed. There's always quite a few lawyers
而取代上议院的则是一个国务会议，其中包含像兰伯特这样政权中的达官显贵；接着是到此时已被大大削减的议会。这就是克伦威尔同意的妥协方案，护国政权也由此拉开帷幕。那么，称克伦威尔为独裁者是否公平？这个词是否太强烈了？我知道20世纪初的人们确实谈论过这一点，他们放眼海外，觉得哦，克伦威尔是现代独裁者的某种原型。
around the parliamentary side, but it rubs up against the army. And here is the rub, because everything in the end that takes place during this decade is ultimately dependent upon the power of the army. If the army doesn't want it, it doesn't really happen. And Cromwell is the significant figure because he's the person who has the kind of trust or enough trust on both
但你认为这种看法是错误的吗？还是说你认为他就是那种可识别的现代模版中的军事强人？不，我不认为他是。我的意思是，你的看法完全正确。这与1930年代的独裁者是一个常见的类比。事实上，提出这一类比的人当中就包括C·V·韦奇伍德（C.V. Wedgwood）——他是这一时期的一位伟大历史学家。几十年后，她在克伦威尔协会（Cromwell Association）的一次会议上非常公开地忏悔，说自己完全错了。很难去反驳这一点。首先，无论真假，克伦威尔一直在不断寻求妥协，并频繁提及“治愈与安顿”（healing and settling）的理念，我认为这是真诚的。他实现这一目标的方式并不总是真诚的。因此布莱尔·沃登（Blair Worden）有一句精彩的名言：克伦威尔是个“装作不知”的惯犯。所以他身上确实有这种狡猾的一面，当事情发生时，尽管他的指纹无处不在，他却可能不在现场。但要说他是军事独裁者——即便他有这种愿望（而我认为他没有），17世纪的欧洲国家也根本不具备任何类似军事独裁的手段。
sides for them to invest in with the prominence he has at this point. However, the nominated assembly does fail because it doesn't give enough money to the army. And this is a common theme throughout this period. And so another figure emerges instead of Thomas Harrison. Well, it disappears to the margins here. And the person who emerges is the figure who's very much seen at this point. and we're talking about 1653-54 here, who is John Lambert, who has had a military career almost as spectacular as Cromwell's, who spends most of the time, while the nominated assembly is bickering, coming up with the world's first written constitution, which is the instrument of government and what that does among many other things is reconfigure the trinity of king lords and commons into a new trinity holy or not of protector which is the position that will be offered to cromwell knowing that he's unlikely
我的意思是，它根本不存在。通信和技术、你所需要的监视手段，在当时根本不可能实现。所以，保罗，基本上，护国政权就是一种长期的演练，试图找出某种框架，让英格兰——甚至整个英国，因为这是第一次为了整个大不列颠——能够运转起来，并为其奠定坚实的基础。从长远来看，正是这一点注定了英国共和国的毁灭，因为这些基础基本上不足以应对克伦威尔的去世。所以在克伦威尔去世后，我们这里有一个来自马修·布彻（Matthew Butcher）的问题：
to take the crown and you have instead of the Lord's a council of state with people like Lambert around him the great and good of the regime and then you have parliament which is pretty denuded by this point so that's the settlement to which Cromwell agrees and that is when the protectorate begins. And is it fair to talk of Cromwell there as a dictator? Is that too strong? I know people did talk at the turn of the 20th century, looking abroad, they thought, oh, Cromwell was a sort of prototype for modern dictators.
复辟是不可避免的，还是存在一条让英格兰保持共和国状态的现实路径？嗯，它本来就不是一个共和国。我的意思是，我认为这就是问题的一部分。当克伦威尔在位时，它并不是一个共和国。它是一个护国政权。它是一种准君主制。它或许有点类似于威尼斯的妥协政体。像詹姆斯·哈灵顿（James Harrington）这样的人（他写了《大洋洲》作为给克伦威尔的建议书）痴迷于古典共和主义和威尼斯共和主义，米尔顿也是如此，他们痴迷于选举产生总督（doge）、
But do you think that's wrong? Or do you think he is a military strong man in a sort of recognizably modern mould? No, I don't think he is. I mean, you're absolutely right. It was a common analogy with the dictator of the 1930s. And in fact, it was one made by, among other people, C.V. Wedgwood, who was a great historian of this period, who recanted very publicly at a meeting of the Cromwell Association many decades later and said she was completely wrong. It's very difficult to argue. One, because whatever is false, Cromwell does continuously seek a settlement and constantly refers to the idea of healing and settling, which I think is sincere. The way he goes about it is not always sincere. Hence Blair Worden's wonderful phrase about Cromwell being practised of not knowing. So there's definitely this slippery side to him that can be absent when things happen, despite his fingerprints being all over them. But military dictator, even if the desire is there, and I don't think it is, there is not the means of anything like a military dictatorship in a 17th century European state.
选举产生护国公的思想，这始终是一个选项。但恐怕广大民众从未真正相信存在君主制的替代方案。议会中的人们在提到诺曼枷锁（Norman yoke）和古代宪法时，经常会提到旧底子、古代宪法。但在大多数人的心中，甚至在许多议会成员的心中，古代宪法就是君主制、下议院和上议院。
I mean, it just isn't there. The communications and the technologies, the kind of surveillance that you need, it's just not possible. So, Paul, basically, the protectorate is a kind of protracted exercise in trying to work out a framework that will enable England, and indeed Britain, I mean, because it's for the whole of Great Britain, isn't it, for the first time, to function, but also to put down solid foundations. And in the long run, that is what dooms the British Republic, is that the foundations are inadequate, basically, to cope with Cromwell's death. And so after Cromwell's death, we've got a question here
事情就是这样运作的。我们只是经历了一个尝试替代方案的空位期（interregnum）。但我认为——而且我认为关于克伦威尔，这一点很有趣——作为一名军事人物，他是极其果断的。当你阅读他在纳斯比战役等行动中的记录时，
from Matthew Butcher. Was the restoration inevitable or is there a realistic path which keeps England as a republic? Well, it wasn't a republic. I mean, I think that's part of the problem. When Cromwell's there, it's not a republic. It's a protectorate. It's a quasi-monarchy. It's something akin maybe to a kind of Venetian settlement. And people like James Harrington, who wrote Oceania as an advice book to Cromwell, were obsessed by classical republicanism and Venetian republicanism, as was Milton and this idea of an elected doge,
例如，当你审视他和他的战役的记录时，这是一个果断的人物。但我认为作为一名政治人物，他从未真正确定妥协方案应该是什么样子的。人们向他提出了各种妥协方案，特别是那些在护国政权末期、或者说在他生命接近终点时涌现出来的人。他们非常渴望找到一个妥协方案。他们知道这个人已经快60岁了，饱受各种疾病折磨，有着艰难的军旅生涯，还要承受这种新型政府带来的压力，他不可能永远活下去，大概也活不了多久了。因此必须找到一个妥协方案。我认为基本上有四种替代方案被摆在桌面上面。第一种是他直接接受王冠。他成为奥利弗一世，并将这变成一个世袭职位。
an elected protector, which was always an option. But I'm afraid that the entire population was never really convinced of an alternative to a monarchy. The old bottom, the ancient constitution, is constantly referred to by people in Parliament when they refer to the Norman yoke, for example, and the ancient constitution. But to most people's minds, even many of those in Parliament, the ancient constitution is the monarchy and the Commons and the House of Lords.
传给克伦威尔家族。但那并不是世袭的。那是一种选举产生的王冠，非常类似于威尼斯。护国公也是如此。你可以承担这个护国公的称号并延续下去，使其世袭或者再次通过选举产生。事实是，最后当他在1658年9月3日那场大风暴中临终时，他说这个安排将是：护国公的职位将传给理查德。所以基本上，选择是一个世袭性质的护国公。但这就是我们当时的处境。因此，在克伦威尔去世时，妥协方案、继承权问题尚未得到决定。从许多方面来看，这非常让人想起克伦威尔自己的英雄伊丽莎白一世所发生的事情，当时对于如何解决继承权问题存在着巨大的不确定性。因此，理查德短暂地担任了
That's the way it works. And we simply have this interregnum where an alternative is attempted. But I think there's, and I think this is interesting about Cromwell here, is that as a military figure, he's incredibly decisive. When you read the records of his actions at Naseby,
护国公，但他其实并不热衷于此，局势随后出现了一种全面崩溃，人们基本上决定：既然我们要搞君主制，那我们还不如把原本的斯图亚特王室请回来算了，于是查理二世回来了。我们对护国政权的历史以及通往该历史的进程进行了一次非常灵巧的纵览。我想顺便说一句，就理查德而言，这并不是理查德是否愿意胜任这个角色的问题——我的感觉是他并不愿意，尽管他极其长寿。所以那本来会挺好的。他一直活到了18世纪。但我认为根本问题还是回到了我刚才所说的那样：他没有军队的支持。
for example, this is a decisive figure when you look the records of his actions at Naseby, for example, this is a decisive figure when you look at him and his battles. But I think as a political figure, he's never really sure what the settlement should be. And he's offered various settlements, particularly by people who emerge towards the end of the protectorate, or at least towards the end of his life, who are very concerned to find the settlement. They know that this is a man in his late 50s, he's wracked by various illnesses, he's had a tough military life, as well as the stresses of this new kind of government, and he's not going to be around forever, and probably not much longer. And so a settlement has to be found. And I think there are basically four alternatives that are presented to him. The first is that he just accepts kingship. He becomes Oliver I and that becomes an hereditary position.
没错。好的。就是这样。好吧。所以，关于军队所扮演的角色的主题，这或许是我们以后可以回过头来探讨的事情。我们应该回过探究克伦威尔与激进派、平民派（levellers）的关系，这也是一个核心主题。我们必须去看看他在爱尔兰的角色。但我想现在，我们应该迅速进入一个商业广告时间。当我们回来时，我们将探讨克伦威尔的争议。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
To the House of Cromwell. But that is not hereditary. It's an elective kingship, rather like Venice. The same for the protector. You could take on this title of protector and continue it and make that hereditary or again elective. And the truth is that at the end, when he's on his deathbed during that great storm on the 3rd of September 1658, and says the settlement is that it will be the position of Lord Protector will pass on to Richard. So essentially, the choice is a Lord Protector of an hereditary nature. But that's the position that we are. And so by the time Cromwell dies, the settlement, the succession has not been decided on. In many ways, that's quite reminiscent of what happened with Cromwell's own hero Elizabeth I when you have a great deal of uncertainty as to how you settle succession. And so Richard briefly serves
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及一小撮演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
as law protector he's not really on for it there's kind of general meltdown and people basically decided well if we're going to have a monarchical system we might as well get the original Stuart family back and Charles II returns so we've we've had a very nifty gallop through the history of the of the protectorate and and building up to that. I think it's worth saying sorry that in terms of Richard it's it's not a question of whether Richard's up for his role I mean I don't get the sense that he is although he's incredibly long lived. So that would have been good. He lives well into the 18th century. But I think the fundamental goes back to what I said earlier. He hasn't got the support of the army.
欢迎回到《历史的剩余》。我们正在辩论17世纪那个伟大的旧事业、奥利弗·克伦威尔的一生与时代、以及英国共和国的命运。与我同行的有顶级圆颅党人多米尼克·桑德布鲁克、花花公子般的骑士党人汤姆·霍兰，以及真正的克伦威尔专家、知情者保罗·莱。
Right. Okay. That's the point. Okay. Okay. So, and on the theme of the role that the army plays, that's something perhaps that we could come back to. We should come back to look at Cromwell's relationship
保罗，我可以以一个问题开场吗？我们在中场休息前刚刚讨论了护国政权的历程和1650年代的整个故事。所以，当像托尼·本恩（Tony Benn）这样的工党政客或一般左翼人士说这是共和主义的一次错失良机时，他们基本上错了吗？我的意思是，从你刚才的言论来看，
with the radicals, the levellers, which is also kind of key theme. And we must come and look at his role in Ireland as well. But I think for now, we should quickly go to a commercial break. And when we come back, we'll look at Cromwellian controversies. I'm Marina Hyde.
听起来你认为根本不存在真正建立某种大致民主的共和国的可能性？无论如何，这终究会是一个君主制的解决方案？嗯，我不认为这是不可避免的。像托尼·本恩和许多历史学家（非常优秀的历史学家）都认同平民派（levellers）。事实上，在我那本平装版的书里，有一张我在伯福德墓地（Burford graveyard）的照片——
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
是的，我很熟悉那里，有三个骑兵的雕塑——是的，打断一下你又一次的快速总结，平民派到底是谁？哦天哪，好吧。平民派是新模范军中的成员、士兵。他们基本上被告知必须去爱尔兰，而他们不想去；但同时他们也处于，可以说是该运动的左翼。
Welcome back to The Rest is History. We are debating the good old cause of the 17th century, the life and times of Oliver Cromwell, the fortunes of the British Republic, with me, top roundhead Dominic Sandbrook, foppish cavalier Tom Holland, and actual Cromwellian expert, who knows what he's talking about, Paul Ley.
欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。我们正在辩论17世纪的美好事业，奥利弗·克伦威尔的生平与时代，大不列颠共和国的命运，与我同行的有，顶尖圆颅党人多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，时髦骑士派汤姆·霍兰，以及真正的克伦威尔专家、知情者保罗·莱伊。
So Paul, can I kick off with a question? We were just talking about the course of the Protectorate and the whole story of the 1650s before the break. So when people like sort of Tony Benn, Labour politician, or sort of generally sort of left-wing people say this was a missed opportunity for republicanism, are they basically wrong? I mean, from your last stuff,
那么保罗，我能以一个问题开始吗？我们在中场休息前刚刚讨论了护国公时期的历程以及1650年代的整个故事。所以当像工党政治家托尼·本恩这样的人，或者一般意义上的左翼人士说这是共和主义错失的良机时，他们基本上是错的吗？我的意思是，从你刚才的内容来看，
it sounded like you thought there was never really a possibility of a genuinely sort of vaguely democratic republic. It was always going to be a monarchical solution one way or the other well i don't think it's inevitable um the people like tony bennett many historians are very good historians identify with the levelers indeed in my paperback version of the book there is a picture of me in Burford graveyard um yeah I know it well with the three um troopers there and don't just to interrupt another of your quick resumes what who are the levelers oh golly okay so the levelers they are uh members soldiers in the new model army um they've been basically told they've got to go to Ireland they don't want to go but also they're kind of on the as it it were, the left wing of that movement.
听起来你认为根本不可能存在真正意义上模糊的民主共和国。不管怎样，它最终总会走向君主制的解决方案。嗯，我不认为这是不可避免的。呃，像托尼·本恩这样的人以及许多历史学家，非常优秀的歷史学家，都认同平民派。事实上，在我书的平装版里，有一张我在伯福德墓地的照片。呃，是的，我很熟悉那里，有三个呃骑兵在那里。呃，打断一下你又一次简短的履历介绍，平民派是谁？哦天哪，好吧，所以平民派是，呃，新模范军中的成员、士兵，他们基本上被告知必须去爱尔兰，他们不想去，但同时他们某种程度上可以说是那个运动的左翼。
They are much more democratic. They want to sort of, they want to get a vote. They want a more, what we would recognise as a more sort of democratic Republican settlement. Cromwell is Blair and the Levellers are Corbynites. These analogies are very, very difficult. The Levellers believing something like they are building a new Jerusalem. And that's the kind of language that has been a part of an English radical tradition ever since, if not before. And Tony Benn would appeal to that. And it's a real tradition.
他们要民主得多。他们基本上希望，他们想要进行投票。他们想要一种，用我们的话来说更像是某种民主的共和派协议。克伦威尔就像布莱尔，而平等派就像科尔宾派。这些类比非常、非常困难。平等派坚信他们正在建设一个新的耶路撒冷。这种语言自那时起，甚至在此之前，就一直是英国激进传统的一部分。托尼·本恩会呼吁这种传统。这是一个真实的传统。
And Cromwell to people like Benn is a kind of a problematic figure, right? Because he's a villain to Ben. Certainly Ben said that Dennis Healy was the Cromwell of the 1970s. Yes, and in many ways, I'd say Dennis Healy is the far more attractive figure, but certainly the more cultivated figure, and certainly, actually, the more effective political figure. But we can debate that at some other time. And in 1650, so a year after charles first death cromwell is
对于像本恩这样的人来说，克伦威尔是一个有点问题的人物，对吧？因为对本恩来说他是个恶棍。本恩确实说过丹尼斯·希利是20世纪70年代的克伦威尔。是的，在很多方面，我想说丹尼斯·希利是一个更有吸引力的人物，但绝对是更有教养的人物，而且实际上，也是更具政治影响力的人物。但我们可以在其他时间讨论这一点。在1650年，也就是查理一世死后的一年，克伦威尔
getting ready to cross to ireland and the army's camped at burford and there is a essentially this kind of mutiny isn't there's a mutiny isn't it they're in the church aren't they they're all in the church and and what does cromwell do well he takes three of them out and he shoots them against the wall at burford church and and yes and there's a kind of memorial to them, isn't there? There is, yes. And it's an interesting memorial because we talk about Cromwell being all things to all men, because it's not just Tony Benn who finds Burford this place of pilgrimage. It's also a place where conservative Brexiteers such as Daniel Hannan eulogise as this birthplace of the free-born Englishman, which of course is the phrase we associate with the most famous of all the Levellers, John Lillman. So it's funny that we say that because I don't necessarily see this
正准备渡海去爱尔兰，军队在伯福德扎营，这基本上是一场哗变，对吧，是一场哗变，对吧？他们待在教堂里，对吧？他们都在教堂里，而克伦威尔做了什么？嗯，他把其中三人带出来，在伯福德教堂的墙边枪决了他们，是的，那里有一种对他们的纪念碑，对吧？是的，确实有。这是一个有趣的纪念碑，因为我们谈论克伦威尔对所有人来说意味着所有事，因为不仅托尼·本恩视伯福德为朝圣之地。这也是保守派脱欧派人士（如丹尼尔·汉南）将其大加赞颂为土生土长的英国人诞生地的地方，这当然是我们与所有平等派中最著名的人物约翰·莉尔本联系在一起的短语。所以很有趣，当我们这么说时，因为我并不认为这种
idea of free-born Englishman being a kind of right or left-wing thing. It can appeal to both sides. Again, we're back to that theme of the fire and the road. Right. And so at Burford, essentially the mutiny gets put down. And one of the things that the Levellers are objecting to is the very idea of crossing to Ireland. So there's a Leveller leaflet that's distributed to the New Model Army
土生土长的英国人的想法一定是某种左翼或右翼的事情。它可以吸引双方。我们又回到了那个火与路的命题。对。所以在伯福德，哗变基本上被平息了。平等派反对的事情之一就是渡海去爱尔兰的想法。所以有一份平等派传单分发给了新模范军
on the eve of the crossing to Ireland. It says, whether Julius Caesar, Alexander the Great, William Duke of Normandy or any other, the great conquerors of the world were any other than so many
在渡海去爱尔兰的前夕。上面写着，无论是尤利乌斯·恺撒、亚历山大大帝、诺曼底公爵威廉还是其他任何人，世界上的伟大征服者除了是一群
great and lawless thieves, which is a kind of very, I mean, that really is a radical idea, isn't it? The whole, you know, the very foundational idea for the crossing to Ireland is presumably for Cromwell
伟大而无法无天的强盗之外，什么都不是，这是一种非常——我的意思是，这真的是一个激进的想法，不是吗？整个，你知道，渡海去爱尔兰的最根本想法对克伦威尔来说大概是
that God wants him to do it, that the Irish rebels are... No, you're... There is that. People always ask me what it's comparable to. There are certain parallels of the conquest of Ireland that does take place under Cromwell and preceded Cromwell and happened long after Cromwell. And comparisons have been drawn by some historians, British historians, comparing it to Nazi atrocities or what happened on the Eastern Front during the Second World War, these kind of comparisons there of genocide. What I think it's most like, most comparable to as a historic event, and I think this is what the Levellers recognised
上帝希望他这么做，爱尔兰叛军是……不，你……确实如此。人们总是问我这可以和什么相比。在克伦威尔统治期间发生、在克伦威尔之前发生并在克伦威尔之后很久发生的对爱尔兰的征服，确实存在某些相似之处。一些历史学家，即英国历史学家，曾将其与纳粹暴行或第二次世界大战期间东线发生的事情进行比较，这些都是关于种族灭绝的比较。我认为它最像、最具有历史事件可比性的，而且我认为这也是平等派所认识到的
and the critics of it recognised, is the Norman conquest. The Levellers and people around them talk about the Norman yoke. They talk about the ancient constitution. That bit I just quoted mentions William. I mean, that's what the allusion is to. Absolutely.
以及它的批评者所认识到的，是诺曼征服。平等派及其周围的人谈论诺曼枷锁。他们谈论古代宪法。我刚才引用的那段提到了威廉。我的意思是，这就是典故所指的。完全正确。
And what happens, what turns out, is wholly akin to the Norman conquest, whereby, and this is attempted in Scotland as well, but far, far more perniciously and aggressively in Ireland, is the Anglicisation of these islands of the islands of britain and ireland but to make them entirely english and the ideology behind that i suspect is that and this goes back to people like harrison but i think it's something that cromwell believes too and those around him is that the english are an elect nation. Just as Israel was the elect
而发生的事情，结果证明，完全类似于诺曼征服，由此（苏格兰也尝试过这样做，但在爱尔兰则更具毁灭性和侵略性得多），是对这些岛屿——英国和爱尔兰岛屿——的盎格鲁化，使其完全成为英国的。我认为其背后的意识形态是，这可以追溯到像哈里森这样的人，但我认为这也是克伦威尔本人以及他身边的人所相信的，即英国人是一个被拣选的民族。正如以色列是旧约中被拣选的
nation of the Old Testament, England is the elect nation of the New. So Cromwell is like Joshua leading the Israelites into the Promised Land. I mean, it's kind of that's what we're talking about. And he simply refers to such allusions. So we've had a host of questions, as you can imagine, about Cromwell, his role in Ireland. So we've got Seamus MacArthur. As a Northern Irishman, we often hear of Cromwell's brutality against the Irish. How much of this is true? How much is exaggerated? What was the source of this animosity? Was it a straightforward religious drive against Catholic Irish? We've got Luke Hennessy with no shortage of other available candidates. Why has a very special place in Irish hell been reserved for Cromwell for so long if the
民族一样，英格兰是新约中被拣选的民族。所以克伦威尔就像带领以色列人进入应许之地的约书亚。我的意思是，这正是我们所讨论的。他只是提到了这样的典故。所以正如你可以想象的那样，我们收到了大量关于克伦威尔及其在爱尔兰的角色的问题。所以我们有谢默斯·麦克阿瑟。作为一个北爱尔兰人，我们经常听到克伦威尔对爱尔兰人的残暴行径。其中有多少是真的？有多少被夸大了？这种敌意源于何处？这是针对天主教爱尔兰人的一场直接的宗教驱逐吗？我们还有卢克·汉尼斯，在有那么多其他候选人的情况下，如果那些暴行被夸大了，为什么爱尔兰地狱里有一个非常特殊的地方长期留给克伦威尔？
atrocities were exaggerated? Okay, I so were they were the atrocities exaggerated um if there were atrocities what was cromwell's role in it um is the uh the black tones in which um island tends to paint cromwell justified um if not why is he such a seen as such a kind of a diabolic figure? This is quite a question. I know. I'm sorry. No pressure. What I tend to think about this is that I don't know whether you've been to Cromwell's house in Ely, in which he spent, in the 800 years that the house has been built,
好的，那么它们是真的吗？暴行被夸大了吗？嗯，如果有暴行，克伦威尔在其中扮演了什么角色？嗯，爱尔兰倾向于把克伦威尔描绘成的那种阴暗色调是正当的吗？如果不是，为什么他会被视为如此魔鬼般的人物？这是一个相当深刻的问题。我知道。我很抱歉。没有压力。我对这件事的看法是，我不知道你是否去过位于伊利的克伦威尔故居，在这座房子建成的800年里，
he spent 20 years connected to it not even living there but it is cromwell's house and i think there's a kind of analogy there with cromwell in ireland cromwell spent about nine months in ireland his actions were decisive sometimes I would argue barbaric, particularly in his treatment of Catholic priests in cold blood. But the facts have often been mythologised, as Cromwell has been. And I don't think that there was one question from one person on Twitter, I noticed, who said, why is Cromwell celebrated in England, but not in Ireland? And I thought, he's not celebrating England. He's almost as controversial character in England as he is in Ireland.
他与它有关的时间只有20年，甚至都没有住在那里，但那是克伦威尔的故居。我认为克伦威尔在爱尔兰的经历也有类似的类比。克伦威尔在爱尔兰呆了大约九个月。他的行动是决定性的，有时我认为是野蛮的，特别是他冷血对待天主教神父的方式。但事实往往被神话化了，就像克伦威尔本人一样。我记得推特上有一个人问过这样一个问题，为什么克伦威尔在英格兰受到庆祝，而不是在爱尔兰？我想，他并没有在英格兰受到庆祝。他在英格兰是一个和在爱尔兰一样备受争议的人物。
I mean, this is a person that still opens up souls. I mean, we'll talk about the statue, but there's much more than that. He's a deeply divisive character. And I've been reminded of it just in the response to this book. But if we look at what happened in Ireland, I think the key to the ruthlessness that Cromwell displays is something to do with this ruthlessness of the army that takes place after the Second Civil War, when they're avenging blood, as they see it. And the avenging blood in Ireland is the Ulster Rebellion, is the Irish Rebellion of 1641, which is exaggerated hugely at the time, but is real. And it takes on the kind of propaganda in England. And I think the rebellion tells or signals to Protestants in England, the people who will fight Charles in the Civil War,
我的意思是，这是一个仍然能触动人们灵魂的人。我的意思是，我们会谈论雕像，但远不止于此。他是一个极具分裂性的人物。对这本书的反响让我再次想到了这一点。但如果我们看看爱尔兰发生的事情，我认为克伦威尔表现出的冷酷无情的关键，与第二次内战后军队表现出的这种冷酷无情有关，当时他们正如他们所看到的，在复仇。爱尔兰复仇的血案是阿尔斯特叛乱，是1641年的爱尔兰叛乱，当时被极大地夸大了，但确实存在。它在英国演变成了一种宣传。我认为这场叛乱告诉或向英国的新教徒——那些在内战中与查理作战的人——
that the people over there are beyond the pale. Sorry for the allusion there, but literally beyond the pale. And therefore, it is time to settle Ireland once and for all. So, Paul, by the standards of war as practised on the continent, is Cromwell's behaviour regarded as excessive even by that? Or is he behaving according to the accepted conventions of war? People behaved pretty badly in the 30 years' war, though, didn't they? Oh, absolutely.
表明那边的人已经不可理喻了。抱歉用了这个典故，但字面意思确实是不可理喻。因此，是时候一劳永逸地解决爱尔兰问题了。那么，保罗，按照欧洲大陆实行的战争标准，克伦威尔的行为甚至连这标准都觉得过分吗？还是说他的行为符合公认的战争惯例？不过，在三十年战争中，人们的表现也相当糟糕，不是吗？哦，绝对是的。
I mean, his defenders always say, well, you know, he was behaving according to the conventional standards. I mean, was he? Well, let's have a look at, I mean, the only way you can really begin to answer this is looking at what happens. James Butler, who's the Earl of Ormond, has brilliantly put together an Irish and Royalist coalition in Ireland, the aim being to secure Ireland as a base to attack England and to bring Royalism back. That's the kind of simple
我的意思是，他的辩护者总是说，嗯，你知道，他是在按照常规标准行事。我是说，真的是这样吗？嗯，让我们来看看，我的意思是，你真正开始回答这个问题的唯一方法就是看看发生了什么。詹姆斯·巴特勒（Ormond伯爵）在爱尔兰出色地组建了一个爱尔兰和保皇党联盟，其目的是将爱尔兰作为攻击英国并让保皇党卷土重来的基地。这就是他所处理的这种简单
equation that he's dealing with. And by about, he's got a strategy together by March 1649. So this is only two months after the king's been executed, if that. He's got a campaign strategy together and appears to have the significant numbers to be able to take Dublin. And in fact, by the end of June, he's about two miles from Dublin. Now, the decisive turning point here, I think, is that the defeat by michael jones at rathmines of this royalist irish force that seems to me to be the decisive victory in this whole campaign that's the second of august because it allows it stalls orman's campaign to one but it allows the new model army, 12,000 battle-hardened, theologically and ideologically primed and experienced British soldiers into Dublin. Plus, they have £100,000 in cash that's given them by parliament so this is a serious force but it's also a force that goes into ireland with cromwell's firm instructions that any soldiers caught looting
方程。大约到1649年3月，他制定好了一个战略。所以这距离国王被处决只有两个月，如果算的话。他制定了一个竞选战略，并且似乎拥有能够攻占都柏林的足够兵力。事实上，到6月底，他距离都柏林大约只有两英里。现在，这里的决定性转折点，我认为是迈克尔·琼斯在拉斯明斯击败这支保皇党爱尔兰军队，在我看来，这是整个战役中具有决定性的胜利，那是8月2日的胜利，因为它不仅阻挠了奥蒙德的战役，而且允许新模范军——1.2万名饱经战火、经受过神学和思想洗礼以及经验丰富的英国士兵——进入都柏林。此外，他们还有议会交给他们的10万英镑现金，所以这是一支严肃的部队，但这也是一支带着克伦威尔严厉指示进入爱尔兰的部队：任何被抓到抢劫的士兵
will be hanged it goes in with a kind of core of discipline androhida is the place that's always mentioned this is a significant town being fought over again and again by both sides. The gateway to Ulster. And Ormond appoints Arthur Aston as the governor of this place. And when Cromwell emerges with his army to be sieged, he's offered the means to surrender. Now, this is the normal process at this time. It's seen endlessly in the Thirty Years' War. It's quite common elsewhere. If you offer the defenders the opportunity to surrender, they will be let go. Aston does not surrender, and his two and a half thousand men or relatives
将被绞死。它带着一种纪律核心进入，德罗赫达是经常被提及的地方，这是一座被双方反复争夺的重要城镇。通往阿尔斯特的门户。奥蒙德任命阿瑟·阿斯顿为该地总督。当克伦威尔率领军队出现并进行围攻时，他被给予了投降的途径。现在，这是这个时期的正常程序。这在三十年战争中屡见不鲜。在其他地方也很常见。如果你给防守方投降的机会，他们就会被放走。阿斯顿没有投降，他的两千五百名士兵或亲属
are there defending this. And in the end, it falls to Cromwell's troops. Now, there are real atrocities there. The burning of St Peter's Church is particularly important. There are people burned alive there. And the sanctioned execution of Catholic priests, which is sanctioned, I believe, all the evidence pointed by Cromwell, is plainly a war crime. Unacceptable. There's no evidence that there was a real slaughter of civilians, although, of course, in such an event, civilians may well be caught up in this.
在那里进行防守。最后，它落入了克伦威尔军队的手中。现在，那里确实发生了真正的暴行。圣彼得教堂的焚烧尤为重要。那里有人被活活烧死。而对天主教神父的有组织处决，我相信所有证据都表明这是由克伦威尔下令的，这显然是战争罪。不可接受。没有证据表明那里发生了真正的平民大屠杀，尽管当然，在这样的事件中，平民很可能会被卷入其中。
And there's no solid evidence of a massacre of civilians. That's where we are. But there is also an element of ethnic cleansing there because the statement is said, you know, once this place is cleared and everyone's left, honest people should come here, i.e. not the Catholic Irish, but it should be left to settlers,
并且没有确凿的证据表明发生了针对平民的大屠杀。这就是我们所处的情况。但那里也存在一种民族清洗的成分，因为据说有这样一种说法，你知道，一旦这个地方被清理干净，所有人都离开后，诚实的人应该来这里，也就是天主教爱尔兰人除外，这里应该留给定居者、
Protestants, English settlers. So we see soldiers killed there. That's, you know, whatever we think of it now, that's part of the deal of war as siege warfare was done then. But priests and friars being executed in cold blood, absolutely not. And it was perceived
新教徒和英国定居者。所以我们看到士兵在那里被杀。你知道，无论我们现在怎么想，这都是当时作为围城战的战争规则的一部分。但神父和修士被冷血处决，绝对不是。即使在当时，它也被认为
as such even then. He then goes south because as Drogheda was the gateway to Ulster, Wexford is the kind of gateway to lenster munster he arrives there in october um the port's still open and in fact it's it starts badly because his forces comes out in marshland a lot of people get dysentery um and david sinnett who is the kind of wexford governor, he again is asked to surrender. And in fact, many of the townspeople, civilians actually leave.
是这样的。然后他向南进发，因为德罗赫达是通往阿尔斯特的门户，韦克斯福德则是通往伦斯特和芒斯特的门户，他在10月抵达那里，嗯，港口仍然开放，事实上，事情有个糟糕的开端，因为他的军队进入了沼泽地，许多人得了痢疾，而大卫·西内特（他是韦克斯福德的总督），他再次被要求投降。事实上，许多城镇居民和平民实际上都离开了。
An English bombardment begins about 10 days later. And Sinnott actually asks for a parley to discuss terms. He's got his own little agenda there. But the commander of the castle, James Stafford, as far as I'm aware, surrenders and English troops enter. And there is some resistance in the town centre of Marcus Great. In fact, this is where Cromwell loses control of his troops. Again, we see something like 2,000 dead. I mean, these estimates are still being looked at all the time. Priest again, no justification whatsoever.
大约10天后，英国人的轰炸开始了。西内特实际上请求进行会谈以讨论条件。他在那里有自己的小算盘。但据我所知，城堡指挥官詹姆斯·斯塔福德投降了，英国军队进入了。市中心马库斯·格雷特发生了一些抵抗。事实上，正是在这里，克伦威尔失去了对军队的控制。我们再次看到大约2,000人死亡。我的意思是，这些估计仍在不断被研究。神父再次被杀，没有任何正义可言。
But just about nine days later, I think it's 19th 20th of october uh in new ross which is another important settlement lucas taff who's the governor commander there surrenders on pretty generous terms and the garrison is actually allowed um to depart with its individual weapons not the cannon artillery that kind of stuff but it can take its own muskets, whatever it has. And so you see a real difference there. You can talk all day, is Cromwell doing this to encourage others not to? Has it worked, in other words, the violence at Drogheda and Wexford? Has it worked at New Ross?
但就在大约九天后，我想是10月19日或20日，在另一个重要定居点新罗斯，那里的总督指挥官卢卡斯·塔夫在相当宽大的条件下投降了，驻军实际上被允许携带各自的武器离开，不是指加农炮火炮那种东西，但它可以带上自己的火枪或任何它拥有的东西。所以你看到了真正的不同。你可以整天讨论，克伦威尔这样做是为了鼓励其他人不要反抗吗？换句话说，德罗赫达和韦克斯福德的暴力行为起作用了吗？它在新罗斯起作用了吗？
Has this message been sent out that this happens, that this is the fate that will happen? Who knows? What I would recommend, and I think there is still a great deal of work going on for this entire campaign and the settlement too, is there's a very good new book edited by, among others, Martin Bennett called Cromwell and Ireland, New Perspectives, which is just about as up to date as a scholarship goes with both British and Irish historians. Patrick Lenehan in particular has done very valuable work looking at the numbers there because the numbers are always contested. And so, you know, that's important. But the point is, so what is the conclusion? I mean, basically, the question is, is there something excessive
这个信息是否已经传达出去，表明这会发生，这就是将要发生的命运？谁知道呢？我推荐的是——而且我认为针对这场整个战役以及定居点的研究仍有大量工作要做——有一本由马丁·贝内特等人编辑的非常好的新书叫《克伦威尔与爱尔兰：新视角》，它几乎代表了英国和爱尔兰历史学家对该学术研究的最新成果。帕特里克·勒尼汉特别做出了非常宝贵的工作，研究了那里的数字，因为数字总是备受争议。所以，你知道，这很重要。但关键是，结论是什么？我的意思是，基本上，问题在于，克伦威尔所做的事情是否存在过分之处，无论是按那个时代的标准还是按爱尔兰历史上其他英国战役的标准，这是否能解释为什么他在爱尔兰拥有这种魔鬼般的地位？还是说有什么外部因素可以解释克伦威尔死后的名誉？
that Cromwell is doing both by the standards of the age and by the standards of other English campaigns over the course of Irish history, that explains why he has this demonic status in Ireland? Or is there something extraneous to that that explains Cromwell's posthumous reputation? Well, I think it's a bit of both. I mean, Cromwell is part of a process, a significant part of a process. But if you look at the 1580s, if you look at the Nine Years' War from 1593 to 1603, during the Elizabethan settlement and the Jacobean settlements,
嗯，我认为两方面都有。我的意思是，克伦威尔是这个过程的一部分，是这个过程的重要组成部分。但如果你看看16世纪80年代，如果你看看1593年至1603年的九年战争，在伊丽莎白时代的殖民和詹姆斯时代的殖民期间，
they are... Yeah, they're far-blooded. They are far, far worse than this. And also, even if the Cromwellian settlement is worse, it's not necessarily Cromwell's work. Cromwell is only there for a relatively brief time. So, you know, by all means, pinpoint blame him there. I mean, we can see that with the treatment of the priests and the friars. It's absolutely appalling. You can see that kind of action in St. Peter's Steeple, in Drog in drada you can see all of that but he's part of a continuum and i think rather as he is in england this kind of bogeyman this is what happens if stability is there he's become a cipher for all the other things and it's why i use the analogy of the house he's in the house 20 years but this house has an 800 year history and he's there in um ireland for a brief period of time although
它们是……是的，它们更加血腥。它们比这糟糕得多、严重得多。而且，即使克伦威尔式的殖民更糟糕，也不一定全是克伦威尔的功劳。克伦威尔在那里呆的时间相对较短。所以，你知道，尽管去指责他吧。我的意思是，我们可以从对待神父和修士的方式中看到这一点。这绝对是骇人听闻的。你可以在德罗赫达的圣彼得尖顶看到那种行动，你可以看到这一切，但他是连续体的一部分，而且我认为就像他在英国一样，这个所谓的妖怪，这就是当政局出现动荡时会发生的事情，他已经成为所有其他事情的代名词。这就是为什么我用房子的类比，他在房子里呆了20年，但这栋房子有800年的历史，他在爱尔兰呆了一段很短的时间，尽管
obviously he also instructs the way uh ireland is settled there too but we're talking about an 800 year history here um we might as well just blame elizabeth the first you know this is a good chance to take the story forward a bit and talk about cromwell's memory because obviously in the 19th century cromwell becomes this incredibly controversial and interesting figure. The Victorians take him up and there's the, I mean, Stephen Clarke, who's a friend of the show, history teacher himself. He's asked questions about Hammo Thorncroft's 1899 statue of Cromwell. And of course, there was a huge controversy about whether there should be a statue of Cromwell at the Houses of Parliament. I think Lord Rosebery, the liberal prime minister, ended up paying for it.
很明显，他也指导了爱尔兰那里的殖民方式，但我们这里讨论的是一栋800年的历史建筑，我们大可以直接责怪伊丽莎白一世，你知道，这是一个很好的机会，把故事推进一步，谈谈克伦威尔的记忆，因为显然在19世纪，克伦威尔成为了一个令人难以置信的具争议和有趣的人物。维多利亚时代的人接受了他，也就是史蒂芬·克拉克，他是节目的朋友，他自己也是历史老师。他提出了关于哈莫·索恩克罗夫特1899年克伦威尔雕像的问题。当然，关于是否应该在议会大厦竖立一座克伦威尔雕像，曾引发过巨大的争议。我想自由党首相罗斯伯里勋爵最终为此付了钱。
The Tories were dead against, the Irish were dead against, which shows what a reputation Cromwell had at the end of the 19th century. And even now, it's a little bit controversial. So do you think to some extent Cromwell is this Victorian, you know, our Cromwell that we have a sense of is a kind of Victorian invention? Because, of course, the Victorians remade him in their own image and used him as a sort of, I don't know, as a template for their own political controversies, didn't they? Well, I suppose it all starts with Carlisle, really, and the idea of this kind of great man, this significant figure.
保守党坚决反对，爱尔兰人坚决反对，这表明克伦威尔在19世纪末的名声有多大。甚至现在，它也还有点争议。所以你认为在某种程度上，克伦威尔是这个维多利亚时代的——你知道，我们所感知到的克伦威尔是一种维多利亚时代的产物吗？因为，当然，维多利亚时代的人按照他们自己的形象重塑了他，并把他当作某种——我不知道——他们自己政治争议的模板，不是吗？嗯，我想这一切其实都是从卡莱尔开始的，关于这种伟人、重要人物的概念。
But you're absolutely right. He's embraced by liberals, but it's the liberal party. I mean, I don't mean liberals in the way that we use it now i'm talking about 19th century liberals like lord roseberry who did indeed pay for the statue and it was deeply controversial at the time this is the time of you know debates about home rule you know ireland is absolutely to the fore of british politics at this time and so this is deeply controversial but you see i mean going back to left here, you see the embrace of this figure Cromwell by people like Isaac Foote, Michael Foote's grandfather, part of this liberal dissenting tradition of which Cromwell that you have here. I think people like Isaac Forte, they really looked at what they were dealing with, would have been absolutely horrified by the kind of ideals figure Cromwell is that I mean I thought I'm sure you were struck in the same way that over the course of the Brexit debate suddenly Cromwell's name was
但你绝对是对的。他被自由主义者所接纳，但这是指自由党。我的意思是，我指的不是我们现在使用的自由主义者的含义，我说的是19世纪的自由主义者，比如罗斯伯里勋爵，他确实为雕像付了钱，当时这引发了极大的争议。这是关于地方自治辩论的时期（你知道，爱尔兰绝对是当时英国政治的焦点），所以这是极具争议的。但你看——回到左翼，你看像艾萨克·富特（迈克尔·富特的祖父）这样的人对克伦威尔这个人物的拥护，他是你这里所说的克伦威尔所属的自由主义异见传统的一部分。我认为像艾萨克·福特这样的人，他们真正审视了他们所面对的东西，会对克伦威尔所代表的这种理想人物感到绝对震惊。我想，我敢肯定，你也有同感，在脱欧辩论的过程中，克伦威尔的名字突然
everywhere again and it was being invoked by people who were siding with the primacy of Parliament and in all kinds of ways and endlessly being mentioned in Irish commentary on Brexit as well and it's as though also people used him Tom to say they said you know that kind of when he goes into Parliament says in the name of God go and all that red seteers was saying that about parliament under theresa may weren't they and it's kind of like whenever um maybe british democracy comes under strain cromwell the memory of cromwell bubbles up whenever relations between britain and particularly england and ireland come under strain again, he is remembered. And perhaps, you know, that's his fate to be a... Yes, I think it is his fate.
无处不在，并被那些支持议会至上的人以各种方式援引，并且在爱尔兰对脱欧的评论中也被无休止地提及。这就好像人们也用他来，汤姆，他们说，你知道，当他进入议会说“以上帝之名，走吧”之类的话时，那些右翼写手在特雷莎·梅执政期间也对议会这么说过，不是吗？这就好像每当英国民主受到压力时，克伦威尔、克伦威尔的记忆就会涌现出来；每当英国与特别是英格兰和爱尔兰的关系再次受到压力时，他就会被人们想起。也许，你知道，这就是他的命运，成为一个……是的，我想这就是他的命运。
I mean, that's what he symbolises, is this break between Ireland and Britain. I mean, that's one of the things he signifies. But everything about him is surrounded by myth, obfuscation, and often error. I mean, Dominic's just mentioned, you know, probably the most famous words he ever mentioned in the name of God go. He never actually said them. I mean, you know, I mean, according to John Morrill's new collection, they seem to derive from a forged version of Cromwell's speeches. That's that's 1767 or something. Paul, next you'll be saying he never said warts and all.
我的意思是，这就是他所象征的，即爱尔兰和英国之间的这种决裂。我的意思是，这是他标志性的事情之一。但关于他的一切都被神话、混淆和常常是错误所包围。我的意思是，多米尼克刚才提到了，你知道，他可能说过最著名的话是“以上帝之名，走吧”。他实际上从未说过这话。我的意思是，你知道，根据约翰·莫雷尔的新合集，这些话似乎源自克伦威尔演讲的伪造版本。那是1767年左右的事。保罗，接下来你就要说他从未说过“warts and all”（全盘接受，不加掩饰）了。
You know, there is so much about which we believe we know about Cromwell, but which we don't know. And this comes back to, you know, there's a terrible ignorance about Cromwell, for better or worse, on both sides of the Irish Sea. I mean, we all know Chesterton's old phrase about the difference between British and Irish history. The Irish can never forget it and the English can never remember it when we're talking about Irish history.
你知道，有关于克伦威尔，我们自以为知道但实际上并不知道的事情太多了。这就回到了——你知道，无论好坏，爱尔兰海两岸对克伦威尔都存在可怕的无知。我的意思是，我们都知道切斯特顿关于英国和爱尔兰历史区别的那句老话：爱尔兰人永远不会忘记，而英国人在谈论爱尔兰历史时却永远不会记得。
But I think this is this absolutely crucial point in British, British and Irish, European, indeed even global history, is one that's still pretty much a blank slate as far as the vast majority of British people go, perhaps even Irish people. And it is something that I think really needs to be amended if we're to understand who we are. Paul, you often don't like modern parallels. And yet, I read in your book an excellent modern parallel, which I heartily approve of, where at the end of your great book, you say, you draw a parallel between Cromwell and Margaret Thatcher, both East Anglians, nonconformists, you know, very decisive when they needed to be very divisive.
但我认为这是英国、英国与爱尔兰、欧洲乃至全球历史中绝对关键的一点，就绝大多数英国人而言，它几乎还是一张白纸，或许对爱尔兰人来说也是如此。如果我们想了解我们是谁，我认为这确实是需要修正的一点。保罗，你通常不喜欢现代类比。然而，我在你的书里读到一个极好的现代类比，我对此非常赞赏，在你的巨著结尾，你将克伦威尔与玛格丽特·撒切尔进行了类比，两人都是东盎格利亚人、不信奉国教者，你知道，在需要的时候非常果断，也非常具分裂性。
Yeah, thought of as austere, but actually incredibly fun-loving. Do you think that, so talk to us about the Margaret Thatcher analogy, because I think that's one that most listeners will find extraordinary. Well, I was being quite mischievous when I did this. Obviously, it is absolutely true that I don't like to draw modern parallels too closely, but I couldn't miss the Margaret Thatcher one, because, you know, as you say, there's this East Anglian non-conformist philo-semite. We forget Cromwell's role
是的，被认为严于律己，但实际上极其热爱生活。你认为——所以跟我们谈谈玛格丽特·撒切尔的类比吧，因为我认为大多数听众会觉得这个类比非同寻常。嗯，我当时写这部分时其实挺恶作剧的。很显然，我确实不喜欢把现代类比拉得太近，但我不能错过玛格丽特·撒切尔这个类比，因为正如你所说，这里有一个东盎格利亚非信奉国教的犹太人支持者。我们忘记了克伦威尔
in resettling Jews in England again. Not that he did this for humanitarian purposes. He did it so that the Jews would convert to Protestantism, Christianity, in the most perfect of all Christian polities. But decisive in war, certainly. Problem with the Irish, that's certainly there as well. There are all kinds of parallels. I was being quite facetious, but I think the most interesting parallel of all, and we talked earlier about the Anglicisation
在让犹太人重新在英格兰定居方面所扮演的角色。并不是说他是出于人道主义目的才这么做的。他这么做是为了让犹太人皈依新教、皈依基督教，从而在最完美的基督教政体中实现这一点。但在战争中当然是果断的。在爱尔兰问题上也有麻烦，这当然也存在。有各种各样的类比。我当时写得很俏皮，但我认为最有趣的类比是，我们之前讨论过
of both Scotland and Ireland that was the plan of this. But I think in the end, even the English people disappointed Cromwell. He described them, and I love this Cromwellian phrase, as under circumcision but raw. In other words, they were on a kind of path to a holiness, a perfection, but they weren't there yet. And indeed, they were a long way off. And I think there was that kind of element with Thatcher. There's a wonderful phrase, I can't remember who did it, I don't know whether it was Vernon Bogden or someone else, who said that Margaret Thatcher wanted to create a country in the image of her father, the Puritan Alderman Roberts,
苏格兰和爱尔兰的盎格鲁化，这是当时的计划。但我认为到头来，连英国人民都让克伦威尔失望了。他形容他们——我喜欢这个克伦威尔式的短语——“尚未受割礼但却生疏”。换句话说，他们走在通往圣洁、完美的道路上，但他们还没到那一步。事实上，他们离那还很远。我认为撒切尔夫人身上也有这种成分。有一个绝妙的短语，我不记得是谁说的了，我不知道是弗农·博格丹还是别的什么人，他说玛格丽特·撒切尔想按照她父亲（清教徒市议员罗伯茨）的形象
and created one in the image of her son. And there's a kind of parallel with Cromwell, because who ultimately follows him? For a brief while, it's his son, but in the end, it's Charles II. And there's this kind of inability to really read the desires of the English people. So the English people, they'd let down Cromwell, they'd let down God, but worst of all, they'd let down themselves. I was about to say, they let down me.
来创建一个国家，结果却按照她儿子的形象创建了一个。这与克伦威尔有某种相似之处，因为最终谁继承了他？有一小段时间是他的儿子，但最终是查理二世。这种无法真正读懂英国人民愿望的情况是存在的。所以英国人民，他们让克伦威尔失望了，他们让上帝失望了，但最糟糕的是，他们让自己失望了。我正想说，他们让我失望了。
And they let down Dominic. On that note, we're going to bid you adieu, to thank Paul. He was lamenting the fact that people don't know much about Cromwell or what they know about him is largely mythic. To get around that problem, I do recommend buying his wonderful book, Providence Lost, The Rise and Fall of Cromwell's Protectorate. Thanks ever so much. We will see you next week. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
他们让多米尼克失望了。带着这句话，我们要向你道别，并感谢保罗。他一直在感叹人们对克伦威尔了解不多，或者他们所知道的大多是神话。为了解决这个问题，我确实推荐购买他的好书《失去的普罗维登斯：克伦威尔护国公政权的兴衰》。非常感谢。我们下周见。拜拜。拜拜。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的底蕴》。如需获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。